Last time when we had the Dawah training
program we had during holidays
most of the Gulf countries are holidays
in July and August. So we chose holidays
ask people to come for about 35 days
for a 25-day training program. And after
that never ever did I get time because
of my busy schedule. Allah has his own
reasons. Never did I ever have a
training program after that. We had many
training programs which were
appreciation and emulation done by
my colleagues, done by my students,
different parts. I've been called to
Medina, Imam to Imam, different
universities, every Islam University of
Malaysia, and different places. Why
don't you conduct any program if not for
25 days, for 10 days? Many princes have
called me, many sheikhs have called me.
I said I'm too busy, involved in the
field of Dawah.
Then, when we started doing workshops,
you'll be shocked to know that we have
called several speakers, only English
speakers, we have called more than 50
different speakers from several
different countries to come to Bombay
and shoot. But, do you know I have not
recorded a single TV talk of myself in
Bombay. Do you know that?
Till today,
we have recorded thousands of episodes
of speakers in English, Chinese,
Mandarin, Bangla, but I have not
recorded a single episode of mine of TV
talk.
Why?
Because I'm busy. I'm wasting days
to record people from China, from
Bangladesh, in Urdu, in English, from
coming out of the world.
Yes, most of my talks, most of them are
lectures.
Lectures have a bigger impact. I say,
"While I'm giving lecture, record me.
What you can get, get. I don't have
time." Yes, I've recorded for other
channels many. For many, I go there, one
shot, 15 episodes. You want for Ramadan?
Okay, 2 days.
Half days, half day I'm doing my work,
next half day I'm giving talks, sleeping
for 2 hours, the next day doing my work,
going to the studio, in one shot 15
episodes.
Tell us 30 days over. What is the
quality?
Not the quality of Peace TV. We'll
discuss on 70. You'll be shocked to know
I have not recorded a single episode of
TV talk.
Yes, I have recorded
interview once only in my life in 2006.
It's a series called as Ramadan a day
with Dr. Zakir.
This was the only series I had which was
exclusively planned.
About 64 episodes of half an hour or 32
episodes of 1 hour where we did in the
next studio, the smaller floor.
And there have been times when the floor
has been made, we have spent money for
the stage. Okay, why not have a session
where some of the students come and
question answer.
On marriage, on career guidance, that is
you know just on the way.
So we did have
workshop where the stage is made for the
speakers. Okay, why not utilize it? The
money has been spent. Half of one more
day doesn't cost more to increase one
day of the studio. The stage has been
done. So it's ready. Okay, I'm ready.
Come on, come there. Full day. Have some
students career guidance, marriage
preparatory course. That's it. And
interviews.
This is the first time
in the span of 25 years
that we're organizing a specialized
shooting program.
The reason is that many people asked,
"Why don't you have this course?"
And one of the person was Sheikh Assim
al-Hakeem.
Who is very knowledgeable, masha Allah.
He's a scholar. He comes on Peace TV and
a dear friend of mine.
And he had come to Bombay twice to
record a series of Umdat al-Ahkam.
One of the best books of Hadith to learn
about Ahkam. And he came twice
for several days, for maybe two three
weeks and recorded 37 episodes. Then
again he came for a month and recorded
another 30 episodes. Total series of
more than 160 episodes. Twice he came
here for a span of two three weeks or
four weeks.
And he had told me the first time when
he met me in 2007
for the conference
that you know
I envy you that the way you quote
scriptures. He's a very good
knowledgeable
person, masha Allah, in the deen of
Sharia.
He said I'd love to
quote from the Bible and do a course
with you. And many other speakers said
that.
Out of humility, humbleness.
Then recently, last year he insisted
that you do so many workshops. You know,
you have done a workshop for me in the
telecom.
Where millions are benefiting. According
to me, if you do a workshop on Dawah
training program, it will benefit
multiple times the ummah more than my
show.
And he coaxed me.
I said, "Inshallah, when Allah gives
time."
It happened so
that in the month of October
I already planned
for the shoot. I plan in advance.
If you fail to plan, you plan to fail.
I had planned my complete schedule of
this year.
And then I thought, "Okay, if I have to
do a training program, I'm already busy.
So, only time slot we could find
is from mid-January to end of February."
I said, "Okay. It's now or never."
So, we decided towards end of October
let's do this program.
And let's record it in such a way
Before that, I thought, "Why not I edit
my old program?
What we have done in '99."
So, I told my staff, "Okay, edit down to
see." But when I saw it
and to edit takes more time than
shooting.
And I saw that program, I said,
"Matters there fine.
It's so old technology. Beta cam at that
time was number one.
Now it is 16 years old.
It can go on satellite, but will not
survive for more than a couple of years.
And for me to edit
those episodes will take several years.
So, my time is more important than the
money.
So, when I'm going to invest in the
editing so much time, which is more time
consuming than doing the program,
I decided, "Let's have
a new program."
Now, to have a new program, minimum I
said that time we had about 1 year's
time to plan. I said, "At least I
require 1 month's time."
So, only time I could find was I came
to India
from the trip of Japan, Korea. I was in
Japan first week of November, then Korea
second week, then was in UAE and Saudi
Arabia landed on 18th of December.
First 18th of December, 1 month planning
I'll do
for the course and
so I told brother Halim I'm flying now.
Give the ad. We hardly had the ad
for less than 20 days.
The previous ad we had for months.
But alhamdulillah so much alhamdulillah
spite of this
short time
without asking representative except a
couple of people we phoned in informal
way
we got a response masha Allah several
hundreds
of people applied.
And we're having it at a time which is
not a holiday time.
So anyone who's coming here is sure that
he wants to be a die.
Not in holiday time many people would
come if it's
off-season time
not a season for holiday
it's more difficult.
More difficult mean more passionate.
More passionate means chances of
getting people who are not passionate to
this
So we kept it at a time which is
not very easy for anyone to come
unless a person is dedicated.
And when we decided
let's have
the session I thought okay, let's have
the third phase.
They said okay, let's increase it to 33
days and we'll put it.
We gave the ad selection was done then I
sat down. Okay, what to put in these
eight days now? Oh, I already committed
eight. What I'm going to speak for eight
days?
Eight hours a day 64 hours?
I was wondering whether I did the right
thing or not. When we sat we realized we
did a mistake.
Eight days is too less.
What to put what not to put?
What to add what not to add. Doing after
16 years.
Then there was juggling, what to
include, what not to include, what to
add, what not to add, what to cut down.
So, imagine
just 2 days before the training program,
we shortlisted the schedule. Schedule
only.
Matter, I'm not so much bothered about
the matter.
Matter, alhamdulillah, Allah has given
a lot of experience, alhamdulillah.
Yes, the only point is in the new
program, there would not be formalized
notes like as we normally give.
Therefore, we mentioned 80%. Normally,
more than 95% of the notes are given. I
reduced it 20% thinking that the new
thing which I'll be speaking, I would
concentrate on the matter rather than
the notes.
Because notes take too much time.
And keeping this training in mind, when
I prepared a lecture, I said, "Okay,
I've prepared a lecture. I'm giving it
successful. What about others?" So, when
I prepared, I started finalizing my
notes. That was in
the mid-90s.
I made the notes. I told my wife, "Write
down."
So that it can be a sample for the
others to copy.
Which you'll get that, inshallah, in the
course of time.
And all my stuff, all the work I do for
the cause of Islam, it is fisabilillah,
no copyrights. You can use it. Don't
distort it. Pass.
Use it.
Whether you benefit,
whether you make money, we have no
problem. My We do that so you can make,
you can sell. If you can get a customer
and charge 10 times, I've no problem.
But don't distort it. No problem.
If someone uses my book and sells it,
I've got no problem. Someone is giving
free, alhamdulillah. Someone is selling,
subhanallah. Alhamdulillah. Each one has
a different customer.
The other people are selling haram
books. He's at least selling book which
is halal and mustahab. So, I've got no
problem.
But don't deceive the people. don't
concoct it, don't change it.
Similarly with this Dawah training
program, I'm aware that many
organizations today are using
the matter, but they change here and
there. The problem is
I'll tell you.
Inshallah.
When you want to copy, copy 100%.
What the ideas of normal people are
copied, but I'll improve it. What I'll
do, I'll copy take 100% and this 10% I
will change. Instead of having a
continuous 25 days, I'll have one day a
week. They change it. Everything notes
are the same.
But one day a week will not get that
impact.
So they think no one has time to come,
so what we'll do, we'll make it easy for
the ummah. So once a week, in 6 months
course is done.
They haven't changed anything.
Are you about to you have changed the
pillar only. How will he learn to do
jihad?
So many of them
copy and they change 10%, 5%, but they
chop off the base only. So when you chop
off the base, you imagine you want to
make a full building of 30 story and you
say okay, I will not make first story.
So we'll start from second floor.
But they don't know what is the base.
Therefore, I tell you if you want to
copy, copy exactly 100%.
As long as it doesn't have copyright,
huh? If it's copyright, then forget it.
If someone says it doesn't have
copyright, copy 100% and come to that
level first. Once you reach that level,
then you change what you want to change.
First at least get that level.
If not 100%, 80%. So to get that level,
you should know how to copy ditto.
Don't change even 1%. Once you get the
results and you achieve the results,
then you can say okay, I want to delete
this, I want to delete that, no problem.
But first achieve that result.
Most of the people take the notes and
they delete this and they change. They
change the answer and they say this is
not right, that is wrong and you have a
mixture and a big mess.
Therefore, you don't get the convincing
results.
All the Rahman
Allahu Allahu
Allahu